the biggest lies the hair industry has
ever taught us water is not good for our
hair and here's the science that proves
it it is true that a lot of what we
think of as hydrated hair isn't actually
to do with water hydrating in hair care
products usually just means conditioning
but water isn't completely bad for hair
the cuticle doesn't seal hair against
water and conditioning isn't all about
protecting hair from water water does
make cuticle scales stand up hair feels
rougher cuticle scales can break off and
it also makes hair stretchier so wet
hair is a lot of the time more fragile
and there is a water repellent layer on
the top of each cuticle scale the F
layer and it gets removed with hair
damage but even if you have completely
undamaged hair water can get inside
really easily in between the cuticle
scales the underside of each scale and
the stuff in between the scales the CMC
is actually really good at absorbing
water and letting it inside so even if
you have completely undamaged hair it
will absorb up to 30% of its own weight
and water within minutes conditioners
deposit in little blobs so it's not
really doing much to block water from
absorbing